all right grandmaster
virgil
what's up
how did you the name grand master
well i got the name grandmaster from the
streets
streets of hard knocks
you know
i didn't start out the grand master
i started out the regular
kid from childhood
going to school
going to church on sunday
trying to get my education coming from a
good family mother and father did a good
family good family they raised me real
good to become
a upstanding citizen
working hard no matter what it was just
like any ordinary middle class
family
so i i got to working
as i graduated went to school done all
the things the kids do
and
as i got close to uh 17 or 18 years old
you know start courting girlfriends and
things that nature
and end up having some kids
so my main focus is to get a job
raise my kids
go to church and become a family man
so as uh as time went on
a lot of people weren't really educated
in life you know not even
uh
people that i thought should have knew
everything
didn't know too much of nothing
because we talked about the 50s and the
60s
so as time went on
the girl got pregnant
not a kid
so i was focusing on that
i wouldn't got a job
as i
said before
but the job that i got didn't work out i
wouldn't got another one that didn't
work out
so i ended up falling off into the
streets life you know we all come from
the struggle
everybody i don't care who they say they
are we all come from the struggle
because we know what the struggle is
that's how our family tree come from
so as time went on
i uh
became a hustler
in the street life
you know i started out uh women getting
on my line you know
and as time went on
i did dabbing this that a little this
and love that you know just trying to
make
ends meet
as time went on i got more educated
being around the top flight players and
things coming up in my life you know we
start
being show rubbing shoulder shoulder
comparing game learning more things in
the street life but thinking all the way
back i was kind of smart in school
so i took my smartness in school and
turned into the fast life
this is in sacramento no this started
out in fresno crazy
so uh
when i got a little older i got a little
more seasoned a little more seasoning as
i went
not knowing
that i was getting smaller and smarter
and something that everybody deemed
unjust
in the streets life
so um
getting back to how you say i got the
grant name grand master
after a period of a lot of years
i became
great
uh in what i was doing in the street
life you know it's not what i chose
uh it just kind of fell in my lap you
know
not knowing my name was become big as it
had became
so i became international known
all around the country so when they run
a make on me about my name to grand
master after a period of years went by
they come up with the understanding by
checking here they're
running the mix they've come to find out
you're one of the greatest that ever
played the game
so that's how i got the name grandmaster
you can't be modest with a name like
grand master
well it's the great great great grand
master but i just cut it for short you
know
so i mean
you seem to be one of the most
successful
pees that i've that i've met
the cars the houses the clothes the
everything well i cut from good stock
you know i'll come up under guys like
charlie montgomery charles v and
uh
frank and ted ward you know the famous
ward brothers you know i come up under
guys that was really successful you know
and what you're around
you become you know i learned that uh
a shark a girl eight feet in a fish tank
with 80 feet in the ocean so if you only
a level
that everybody understand the same thing
you're not growing no higher than that
so you got to go outside that box
and that's what i did
i could become worldwide and i went
outside the box of the average person
thinking so that kept me ahead
i've been blessed
god been in my life all my life even
though i was in the street life i put
god first
you know because i'm a god-fearing
person
and i've been praying every day of my
life
you're right yeah
what personality trait do you possess
that really helps you succeed and get
ahead
well i have uh
i don't take less for the best
you know i'm i don't want to become a
survivor
my mentality is a thriver you know
and i start out
i'm i'm
i become what what i was doing a long
time ago the way i was taught
i kept that same mentality
you know you have to thrive for what you
want in life
you're not willing to compromise
no i don't i don't compromise
when i see something i go get it i've
always been that way since i was a kid
yeah you need you need that mentality
yeah you got you have to you have to
have strong will to do
uh strong things in life you know you
you know a lot of people just give up
the first chance they get to just give
up fall by the wayside don't never get
back i never took that that uh attitude
after doing so many of these interviews
of people in the game yeah it seems like
almost everyone is broke
well a lot of these young guys are just
you get broke from the mindset
that's why i say about the fish tank
shark and fish taking the ocean you get
broke from this mindset you're a victim
of what you're around
all you're surrounded you're a victim of
it because you can't learn nothing past
that you had good good role models as a
kid
i had good role models as a kid for sure
but i always moved past
like i said i never took less for the
best i always looked past
what my my theory was about life you
know i should ride by the rich people's
house and look at them and say why i'm
not living like this why we're not live
why are we over here
and all the rich people over here
that'll make no sense no way out you
know
something's not right
but i end up moving out there with the
rich people you know ain't no buying a
house see i was buying
big houses
when all the rest of my friends were
still on the west side you know
i never wanted that
i always wanted something better
something bigger and i still strive for
that
you know i had my family my kids was my
focus
to take care of them get them a good
life because i
take them as i look at myself
with things i used to look at coming up
as a kid wonder why my mother and father
wasn't driving better looking but you
know that affects a kid as young you
know
and i didn't want my kids to have to
live like that my kids all my kids have
little
over average betting all the kids that
they're around you know
for that particular reason
and uh i took all my kids out of the
streets you know
they never missed a birthday always had
everything they wanted
because they had my first priority any
kids following dad's footsteps
actually
i have one
and he's just an image of where i come
from you know everybody else has got
their head screwed on top i got rappers
in my life i had a kid
one of my kids is cali cash they got a
grandson and caked up will their major
artists
in their
entertainment field you know so we're
trying to take that to the next level
you know um
my other son he
was an image of where i come from he
didn't you know he didn't ever want to
do anything work so he's still on the
road he's been around the world
seven eight times and uh you know he's
doing well for himself and i'm proud of
him for it you know because i got him in
the right direction i can't tell them
what not to do they got their own mind
on what they're going to do all i can
tell them what's best for them and give
my experiences
try to help them along the way
it sounds like you always believed you
were destined for something great
well yeah i believe that as a kid i
still believe it i'm still thriving for
it
i uh my past life
is uh was just a journey to get where
i'm at now because everything all the
negativity people feel like the life is
is uh
the unjust
but
as time go time change you can't get
stuck in shadows of the past
you got to elevate the way you think
because a lot of people don't think all
they do is follow
you know they got more sheep than they
got shepherds you know i just happen to
fall on the line i'm a shepherd you know
i'm a leader you know
what do you think these young
younger
p's don't don't get
well it's a generation gap you know a
lot of people don't mind not look at it
might not agree with that
but you know
as you look up my like my father in them
they come up a certain way they work
hard
they take care of families and this and
that
when we come up
it was just another generation come up
with our mindset was thinking different
so kids raised kids sometimes whatever
kids think what they have on their mind
that's what all their friends do a lot
of them become rappers because that's
what all their friends do a lot of them
become game bangers because that's what
all their friends do
if it's everybody all their friends got
a job go to work that's what they would
do
but the generation changes things the
next generation going to change
something else so it's hard to keep up
with because you never know where the
mindset might go
what is it about
the the poor communities the the hood
that
is broken because there's so many that
are just not
going anywhere in life they're just
hustlers and they're just gonna
stay broke hustlers for the rest of
their lives well
you got to look at it like this here
back in the 70s
late 60s and 70s you had the drug gang
it came into play
it spread all over the world
it was money
that played out a lot of people still
stuck on
the same thing that it was before
it's no more money in drugs like it was
back then you can get rich back then in
a year
you can't do that in 10 years now it's
chances that you take you lose
everything your life
your freedom everything
so you have to adjust to the next phase
if you're only thinking on one thing
then one thing gonna run out sooner or
later
nothing stays good forever
you've got to keep advancing the way you
think and keep up with the pace of life
that's what i was great at
you know
yeah it's like playing football when i
was playing football
i was a running back
i could have six people lined up
but i could go full speed ahead
and go to the left and shift back
and they take one step and i'm going for
the touchdown that's the same thing is
with life
they can't adjust quickly they don't
think it's fast you know
everybody's
built with a gift of something
i'm so happy that just happened to be
mine
i don't say that
i tell all these young peas
they i don't want to think that it's
that easy because i make it look easy
it's not easy at all it's a fight to the
end
it's it's a television fight it'll never
stop you got to be smart enough to
adjust what to do keep your pride to the
side because a lot of them be
brought up
uh
with mislead misguided i hear it all the
time right now
so you have to be able to just in
mid-air to make you win
you got to stay up to pace with things
just like a mechanic working on a car
any
any mechanic you could have took a
cadillac to our mercedes too
and i'm gonna go past that
uh because that's just something
everybody can afford but that same
mechanic could work on that cartoon you
can't work on it now you gotta go back
and revamp yourself re-read
read uh invent yourself keep staying up
to pace with everything you've adapted i
doubt all the time
what do you make of how the game has
kind of
changed into like you know there's
internet
you know there's technology that's
that's kind of taken given given well
that's something different what i
understand it was street life when i was
there
that's that's what i was getting to
about the youngsters
they vamp
into the internet because
uh
the law started getting worse
on prostitutes
they start bearing down it's a whole
thing as a money game you know
they don't really care about that
they just figure out a way to make the
money so it's all riding down on them
so now they figured they recreate
themselves for something to do something
with the inside game i don't know about
the inside game
all i know is something about the
streets you know i've been 17 18 19 deep
from the streets because i mastered the
game
yeah
i mastered the game
and
big games play smooth out of sight you
know
and
you don't
you only put people up on something they
qualify
you know game recognized game you know
can't nobody walk in here i can talk to
them for five seconds tell what they're
made of
i can see them walking down the street
and read their personalities
so
it's you got to be educated in
everything that you do
you can't go on that guessing
you got to be blessing you got to have a
blessing with it
come from upstairs
you got to do was what you meant to be
everybody don't have the same blessing
everybody don't have the same uh
theory the same thoughts that's what
confusion comes in
so i assume some of your wealth has come
from other things other than
prostitution right well you said you
have real estate investments well
this is what it goes back to
you have to elevate
you don't get stuck in the shadows of
the past or get stuck on stupid
if i have one prostitute give me two
thousand dollars a day
i got sense enough
to stack that two thousand
four years straight spin what's
necessary lay back and stack
the next man might take this
and go jack it off if they thinking
they're gonna get the same thing and
it's stopping midair
now you're through the woman run off she
go to jail she gets sick
you're stuck you don't have enough to
stack your money you got to know how to
stack
uh a foolish money will part quickly
i've been the biggest fool out of
anybody that's why i'm so educated
i don't lost more than that person will
ever have in life i've lost it
i've been a damn fool and i admit that
so i teach and i preach to youngsters
about life because i don't want to have
to go through that
you know
what do you think of the future of the
game
well
i don't think anything about the future
of the game
arcade life as it come
and see i'm a one-man army a lot of guys
need
a crowd of guys like a set trip in order
to feel secure in their life
i take it head on myself so
i ever come that's how i'm dealing with
it i'm educated enough to take things to
the next level so i'm waiting for the
next phase of it we're going to keep
driving until some come to closure you
know but i believe in myself
i always have
i got a strong belief in myself but i
know that's what it take to win
what was the most difficult period of
your life
when
the most difficult time in my life is
when
i had worked for 20 years straight
and was secure for the rest of my life
and made one mistake
by trying to help a friend of mine
and
they took everything i had
that was most and laid me down that was
the most worstest thing ever happened to
me my whole entire life
but then when i got to as years went by
when i got to think about it
you know anything could happen in life
as life go but you don't see that it was
forwarded to you you think everything
gonna stay the same like i said before
but thing changes on you
i experienced
don't have a worry in the world
to having a headache for five years
i lost eight women at the time
everybody ran off the left
uh
i went laid down so i'm not
nine mo
while i was gone
because they put me in a position
when i have no alternative to do what i
know
keep getting my money
so that's what happened and when i got
uh
my name was so big
in the city
and around the country
that when they took me to court they had
me on tv for like
two months straight they stopped the
football game
during this time
because
they got the man that they've been
wanting behind another friend of mine
making a mistake back in the day
and i had another guy that i tried to
help then he turned around and lied on
me
and that's what got him to take
everything i had and everything i had
was paid for
so that wiped me out
but it it gave me it educated me you
know
you got to put protection on yourself at
that time i was full fled in the life
so i didn't have no protection on myself
i wasn't educated
i was just leaning on the game itself
you know
but going to prison
taught me so much about health
education
what you need to know
what you didn't do
how to put protection
and i learned a lot during those five
years
i first go to school
uh 12th grade yeah
yeah i graduated
but i went to go to college and they
wouldn't let me in that day
and that killed it
they let me in that day i'd have been in
college
if drugs ever been a part of your life
well
this is what i try to explain to people
a lot of guys
see
when you i'm explaining break it down to
you
when you in the game
the game is on the umbrella of several
hustles
you got teal tap
you got drugs
you got short chains
you got uh
con men
you got
uh
the jury game
you got three cars molly
that all consists of hustle that sum
under that umbrella
now i was taught as a youngster
as a youngster
about the drug game i didn't know
anything about the drug my life was
women you know
and it took me years
before i affiliated myself with any drug
i never sold no drugs
i never dealt no drugs
but
i was smart enough by saying i was ahead
of people i was smart enough
to put my money up
and get out the way because that's the
way i was taught
so that
took me out of the loop
of the dealing drugs but i have put my
money up but that was years ago you know
it was years ago i haven't been
affiliated with that
in years and years and years
all i do right now is dress rest and
ride
and i like my life to be easy i don't
like nothing hard i don't like to take
chances unnecessary chances i'd have
been through all that
just my name alone
i'll get you in trouble back in the day
not now because i've been retired so
long now all that's in the past
i'm a really tired guy and i'm in the
legit business i have the closing line
i have a uh
benefit shop that you can get your taxes
done
and uh
i have a lot anything legit that's what
i'm down for and i teach all the kids
don't think because you see me
doing this and that i'm entertainment
life that go with the
rappers
the books
the movies all that's under
entertainment
i can't get away from my past because i
always like looking good i always like
smelling good i always like dressing
good that's part of it just like what
the preacher told me you know there's
nothing wrong with looking good and
having money just because i'm in church
that's not going to stop that
this is just what we made from
but i am a god
fan person and god is in my life ain't
gonna always be in my life
and i'm out there to help the youth
go get educated
don't leave them straight laugh along
nothing good could come out of it i even
tell my son that but we grown i can only
tell them so much
but like i say i'm proud of them because
they do listen and they stay out the way
and he's all right so
long as he all right i'm all right but i
take care all my kids grandkids have
kids and died i wouldn't bury them in
other states other city you know i'm uh
i'm i'm a father to all my kids
and you're in their lives in their lives
yeah whether the mothers were together
or not stayed in their lives
if i didn't say neck to the mother the
kids always in my life
you ever wish your life had taken a
different path
risked my life did you ever wish your
life had taken oh most definitely
because you know when you
when you come from where i come from
and the things that didn't happen in
life the much money's getting lost the
time
and all that you have to think back
about your past life
because
when you look up and here's a person
that's got a job
that's doing super great
better than the person in the street
you have to think about it twice
you know a working person might not have
what i have ever accomplished in life
but
they're all right and they play safe
i should have been worth 50 million
dollars because i had that kind of
action in life i could have been 10 11
things different other than what i was
but
by me
being in that
fish tank instead of the ocean i was
surrounded by the same type of people
that i was i come up with and that's all
we knew
it wasn't a lot but at that time we were
winning
you know if you back then you're doing
things like we were doing you like the
president of the united states when you
ride through everybody's salute
so it's a psychological game you know
it's a larger thing in your mind
and you you make yourself believe it but
would i like to took another path yes i
would i wish i don't want it just like
the other guys be doing
have a job
take the time
let time go you know what they say about
the turtle
the rabbit and the turtle rabbit get
tired and turtle keep going
i haven't seen it i'd have witnessed it
with my own eyes
so yeah i would shot him with that root
what's your biggest regret
what's your biggest regret
that i didn't uh
go to school and get educated and uh
become something more than what i became
you know
so you know it's just catch up time you
know it's a race now you know i'm
getting ready to be 77 years old
you're gonna be 77 77 yeah so uh
i feel like a lot of it was a waste time
but it's a lot of experience in life a
lot of education you gotta pay for
education i don't care what you do you
gotta pay for education
so i paid a lot for education
but i know not i'm more smarter now i've
never been in my life i'm more patient
now than i've ever been in my life you
feel at 76 years old that you are
still as capable and you have the energy
to do everything you want to do when you
were
30. i wouldn't say that no slow down
yeah i slowed down a lot i used to have
any patience at all
the thing about it is that
had i known
had i been aware
i took another route all together
different
you know i'm not proud to say you know
all the glitters is not gold you don't
know what a person go through in life to
become
uh a top flight or whatever you know
you don't know what a person go through
life when they get up every morning go
to work and they're cold and raining and
and uh
getting sick and still got to go you
don't know what a person goes through in
life
and that's in on all levels you don't
know what you're doing to have to do
what you're doing
people don't can't see that it looks
easy
but it's more to it than that it's more
it's always more to it than what it
looked like
but i thank god that i'm blessed
i have more good than i had bad
so that's the advantage that i got i've
been winning for almost 60 years
straight because i stayed on top of my
business
and i was always smart enough not to be
a follower be a leader
i got my own mind
because a lot of people don't mean you
know good to surround you
you know
and you're gonna fall upon it that
you're gonna learn it as you go
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important lesson i learned is
to be patient
and uh stay focused
and keep doing
uh
something on the positive note
get your education because education is
what win
i wish i get almost uh
60 years old
to really just start writing i never
knew i could write
it's waste and talent that you have by
just getting stuck on stupid autumn life
because you got to explore and see what
bring all your potential out
of whatever you're capable of
you can't just leave it limited because
when you think this is going to be your
glory land it might be something over
here that you're missing it's just like
the guy that had the oil
on his land
and went cross-country searching for
gold
sold his house and moved all the way
across country
and when he got over there three years
later who he sold the house to they
found oil on it
and he went off and left his riches
moving too fast
you know
so sometime it'd be right there and you
don't even realize it just like that
with me you know it's been right there
and i didn't realize
i i thinks back sometime now about my my
uh
i would say
i'm not gonna say stupidity i'm gonna
say ignorance
you know when you're ignorance that's
things that you're not aware of you
don't know
so i i had big advantages to be very
very wealthy
even from the street life even from this
even from that
i just needed to be
uh
more more
knowledgeable about things
and i just i i just had to
i had
i had to grow go and grow you know so
i'm very very educated now not knowing
everything
but i got a direction where i'm going
all right virgil thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out there
ain't no doubt i'm here to win it keep
going yeah
you